[Música]
pues hoy en directo nos vamos hasta
Centroamérica puntualmente hasta
Nicaragua en donde en el marco del día
internacional de la mujer el gobierno
del presidente Daniel Ortega liberó a
unas 230 mujeres que estaban cumpliendo
condena en prisión hay temor y hay mucha
preocupación porque algunas de ellas van
a pasar a un régimen de convivencia
familiar y diferentes ongs en este país
denuncian que allí pueden enfrentarse a
episodios de violencia doméstica vamos a
conversar sobre el tema con Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo corresponsal senior de
France 24 en Centroamérica Andrés muy
buenas noches para usted y comienzo
preguntándole justamente por esas 230
presas que fueron liberadas en Nicaragua
solamente por ser el Día Internacional
de la mujer hay que decir
Santiago muy buenas noches ya lo había
anticipado el gobierno de Daniel Ortega
cinco días atrás que este 8 de marzo Día
Internacional de la mujer liberaría a
230 presas comunes con la condición de
que irían a vivir en una convivencia
familiar en otras palabras les dio una
Libertad condicional bajo el techo de
una casa por cárcel la condiciones que
fue pues empresas comunes es decir que
los delitos que hubiesen cometido en el
pasado fueran de menor gravedad sin
embargo como usted bien lo dijo Es un
momento que denuncian organizaciones
feministas y ongs en el que
presuntamente se incrementan los números
de feminicidios por los ataques en
contra de ellas en aras de cobrar
venganza pero este tipo de liberaciones
masivas suelen ocurrir en el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega en días conmemorativos
como el Día del Padre el día de la madre
el día de la Revolución sandinista o el
día de la Navidad Incluso en el año 2022
fueron liberados cerca de 5.000 presos
comunes si en el periodo del 2014 al
2022 cerca de 40.000 esto también como
para liberar las cárceles del
hacinamiento aún así la ministra de
gobernación María Coronel le dijo a
estas mujeres que es una oportunidad
única que se presenta solo una vez en la
vida y las exhortó a que dieran su mejor
versión de la sociedad Andrés también
destacado en Nicaragua en la jornada de
hoy el cierre de esas dos universidades
que están ligadas a la iglesia católica
que ya sabemos que hay una relación muy
tensa entre la Iglesia Católica
nicaragüense y el gobierno de Ortega
Murillo
así es Santiago un día después del duro
golpe de en contra de El Libre Mercado y
de la libre empresa ahora el agua fría
le cae a la academia Y es que el diario
oficial la gaceta publicó que dos
grandes universidades nicaragüenses
quedan completamente clausuradas la
universidad Juan Pablo Segundo y la
universidad cristiana Autónoma que
representan a más de 10.000 estudiantes
y que perdieron completamente su
personería jurídica el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega adujo que el cierre de
estas universidades se presenta porque
no presentaron a tiempo estos estados de
cuestiones estos informes financieros de
patrimonio de ingresos y de egresos de
manera tal que para el Ministerio de
gobernación estarían incumpliendo con la
ley que las regula como las asociaciones
de esta manera el gobierno de Ortega
exhortó instó al consejo nacional
universitario para reubicar a estos Diez
mil estudiantes afectados como también
instruyó a la procuraduría para
decomisar todos los bienes de
universidades y ponerlos a nombre del
estado de aquí cabe Resaltar que el
congreso el parlamento nicaragüense el
año pasado usó estas infraestructuras
para crear tres nuevas universidades
pero son fuertemente criticadas por la
oposición porque se dice que allí se
está impartiendo una educación superior
con tendencia hacia el gobierno de esta
manera con el cierre de estas dos
universidades se ilegalizaron un total
de 19 centros de educación superior
desde el 2021 hasta ahora y ha sido
motivo para que muchos de los rectores
vivan ahora en el exilio